and so I took it into my own hands and
that was when I was when I was 22 when I
realized that if you have issues in your
life nobody other than you is going to
fix them and I used to go to the medical
community because that's what I learned
to get help and that wasn't working for
me so I started to delve into diet I
went back to school for biomedical
degree which I didn't end up finishing I
did a couple of years of that and I
started delving around in diet so like
long story is short I ended up only
eating meat which I think is also kind
of what helped people start following me
because they're like What's this weird
old beef woman do that fool I'm still on
it so literally only six years you only
eat meat still yep
told me through a day's diet then uh
Stripling Stripling steak that's you
wake up in the morning what do you have
for breakfast strip wine what do you
have a lunch straight line what do you
have for dinner sometimes strip loin in
soup and dinner same yeah yeah three
steaks a day yeah yeah